the Hui military spokesman in Yemen has
confirmed to aljazera that their
Fighters have hijacked a ship owned by
an Israeli businessman in the southern
redc at least 22 people were on board
the Galaxy leader which was on its way
from turqu to India Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin nety who condemned
what he described as an Iranian attack
the Galaxy leader is sailing under the
flag of the Bahamas ship tracking
agencies showed it traveling in the Red
Sea on Saturday but they haven't
received any location signals since the
ship past Southern Saudi Arabia the
houthis are threatening to take further
military action in response to Israel's
war on Gaza John Holman has been
monitoring us reaction to uh that in
Washington
DC the United States National Security
Council which advises uh the white it's
the top body advising the White House
and the president on security has said
that this is a flagrant violation of
international law it's demanding the
release of the ship the release of the
crew and it's saying that it's going to
take the appropriate next step with the
US's allies and with its United Nations
uh Partners us officials uh have also
other mediate Outlets have been saying
of confirmed to them uh that uh the
fighters actually Rell down from a
helicopter to take over this cargo ship
the US has been beefing up its presence
uh in the area uh it says to try and
prevent escalation
of the fighting and of the violence
since October and more countries
becoming involved uh and it's also said
that it's doing that to assist in
Israel's security and there's been two
US aircraft carriers that have been
deployed to the Middle Eastern Area with
the accompanying warships that go with
them and in two separate incidents over
the last month they say that they've
intercepted missiles or drones that have
been coming they say from Yemen heading
either towards Israel all heading
towards American vessels and they've
managed to down them but they obviously
didn't manage to deal with this
situation joining me now to discuss this
is Ibrahim frat associate professor of
conflict resolution at the Doha
Institute for Graduate Studies on a
scale of 1 to 10 how much of a problem
is this for the Israelis when they are
now seeing that either Israeli owned
boats or other interests can be directly
targeted outside of Israel well I think
it's quite serious I would say probably
out of 10 uh because this represents to
me is the first step in the expansion of
the war to the region and this is
something that Israel and the United
States have been seriously trying to
prevent because one they don't want to
expand uh with fight other Wars while
they are fighting in Gaza and the other
thing is that the US Global strategy is
not the Middle East at the moment it's
about China and uh Russia and Ukraine
so the United States does not really
want to be pulled into this but we are
seeing the Dynamics of the conflict are
pushing in that directions and actually
that this is step is coming of the H is
uh taking the ship in in the M State
this is like after 45 days of the War uh
this was expected actually much earlier
because the uh what's called the access
of resistance are closely connected and
they they function as one unit between
you're talking about the various
Regional groups that have links to uh
Iran whether it's the huthis hisbah
Hamas also whether it's political
operational Financial exactly that's the
access of resistance groups in the
region isah Hamas Shi uh in Iraq as well
and yes they have uh links to Iran as
strong links but again Iran keeps uh
saying that they also have their
operational and decisions and their own
decisions of where to go and the threats
have been actually from day one that
these groups would intervene in order to
support Hamas and we saw hisbah actually
the following day on October 8th October
8th hisbah was giving signs and started
to go you know to do these kind of
things but now this is a pretty
significant escalation from the houthis
you're right the threats were there from
day one and then from the houthi
specifically they fired um ballistic
missiles at Israel which were
intercepted and now They seized this
tanker or this this ship what are the
options for Israel here well Israel
doesn't have many options here actually
it's Israel only option is just U
looking at things of the only way that
they do it which is keep threatening and
by force and trying to by force to
achieve everything and this doesn't work
because this is going to uh threats and
escalation is going to lead to
escalation as well and this is what's
happening uh this is not the first time
uh of the hu's intervention in in this
War uh we saw that they fired ballistic
missiles from and and drones from from
Yemen um so this is actually the second
stage of the escalation missile once
it's intercepted problem solved from the
Israeli perspective the ship on the
other hand they're holding that ship
there are people on that ship uh the
ship is connected to uh Israeli business
interest that situation is going to be
ongoing as of now and this is uh let's
remember this is going through the mate
this is like the the the state that
connects all of Europe to South Asia
this is a very very
vital Waterway exactly so this is this
is very serious like what's happening
and the hes have they can disrupt the
entire area they're in control of the
Mandate they're a non-state actor
they're milicias they've been fighting a
war for S years now with Saudi Arabia so
just a few additional bombs of bombing
them is not going to make a big
difference they've been living this for
seven years so even the United States
the interesting thing we haven't seen
any response from the United States to
the escalation that the H is took in the
MRA which usually something this is the
United States would rush into making
threats as well or but again the US
keeps pushing that does not want to uh
be pulled into this but the way it's
managing this war um actually the
dynamic of the Dynamics of it is pulling
necessarily the United States into this
war because today we're seeing um uh
kidnapping ships in the Mandate tomorrow
we're going to see something else and
we're going to expect something from
probably in Iraq and and you know it's
on you foresee further escalations the
US has already made a major major move
here and it was several weeks ago when
they sent two uh Naval uh aircraft couns
uh to the region